i'd like to welcome welcome you all here
this evening nice to see you all
and i'd now like to ask
the reverend kim leafy to
lead us in
[Music]
this
prayers
it is a joy to be with you as you gather
here again this evening and i invite you
now to join me as we commend this time
over to the moon
so let us pray
dear wise and loving father we say thank
you for the many and abundant blessings
we thank you for life itself
for the measure of our health
for sustenance and for friendship
we thank you for the ability to be
involved in useful work
and for the honor of bearing appropriate
responsibilities
amen
lord in the scriptures you have said
that people ought to obey the governing
authorities
since you have established those very
authorities to promote peace
and order and justice
therefore i pray for mike
and for the assembled council
and i am asking that you would
graciously grant them wisdom to govern
a sense of welfare and the true needs of
the people
a key thirst for justice and
righteousness
confidence in what is good and fitting
the ability to work together in harmony
even when there is honest disagreement
and for personal peace in their lives
and a joy in their task
i pray for the agenda set before them
today
please give an assurance of what would
please you and what would benefit those
who live and work in and around our
beloved rockford
amen
i'm now going to pray the lord's prayer
and if you would like to join in with
this prayer then please do so
[Music]
thy kingdom come
thy will be done on earth as it is in
heaven
give us this day our daily bread and
forgive us our trespasses
as we forgive those who trespass against
us
and lead us not into temptation
but deliver us from evil for thy is the
kingdom the power and the glory
forever and ever
amen
and the blessing of god almighty the
father the son and the holy spirit
be with you and all whom you love
this night and forevermore
amen
go well have a good evening
thank you thank you
members please be seated
okay
members apologies i uh admitted to do
the evacuation instructions before i
introduced our chairman
so
should we be required to evacuate the
building would you please leave the
building via the rear doors to the hall
turn right go through the two sets of
double doors to the car park where it is
the assembly point please do not delay
your evacuation to collect any
belongings please do not return to the
building until given permission to do so
by council staff
please note that the meeting will be
audio recorded
please switch off mobiles or turn them
to silent thank you
members
when i invite you to speak
please wait until the microphone is in
front of you
before speaking
as as the microphones are needed for the
hearing loop
and the audio recording
i would remind members though
if you even if you're not speaking the
microphones are switched on and we'll
stick pick you up still pick up if
you're speaking and you're not actually
speaking
they're already switched on
so all you need to do is to adjust them
and please make sure the microphone is
directly in front of you before speaking
members voting will be done by a show of
hands in line with the constitution
and i'll ask for a show of hands
then
then against the recommendation and then
for abstaining
given the size of the room and the
number of us present
can i please ask that you put your hands
up clearly
remembering what it was like when you
were at school
high in the air
so you can easily be seen by all
and leave it and up until you're asked
to lower it
the normal rules of debate apply no
member should speak or
for any longer than five minutes
and can i please ask you not to repeat
anything previously said
all those indicating was to speak will
be given an opportunity to speak once
right a agenda item one apologies for
absence
i have councillors
uh aj cross
jn gooding
this is j r gooding
and t d knight
and councillor jack lorman and
councillor june lumley
members the
item two
the meeting of the
annual meetings
held on the 17th and the extraordinary
meetings held on the 14th of june
are you happy for me to sign these
minutes of the annual meeting held on
the 17th of may and the extraordinary
meeting
held on the 14th of june is that agreed
members
gender item 3
declarations of interest
are there any in declarations of
interest
i remind you members if anything should
come up during the course of the debates
please indicate at the time and we will
make under the necessary note
a gender item form
a gender item for announcements for the
chairman leader or head of paid service
i'd like to take this opportunity
of saying a few words
those were at the garden party and i
thank you all for coming along that did
to the garden party
will know my chosen charities but those
that weren't able to attend
it is trust links
who are based in rochford
and advancement through football
in great wakering
i've got a couple of events that will be
coming up
the first one
is on the 28th of august
and it is a riverboat cruise
from the paper mill lock to haybridge
basin
if anybody wants any details if you'd
like to see councillor williams after
the meeting he will have all the details
or myself
i also plan to have perhaps a couple of
quiz nights during the course of the
year
and i've been over to felness today on
another matter and had a chat with the
heritage center there and hopefully with
the permission of the
uh mod we may be able to do a tour
around founders island for those that
have never been to found this it's a
fascinating place
it's very historic and uh it's very
interesting to visit
okay thank you members
he said did the leader wish to make any
announcements just to clarify thinking
okay agenda item five
presentation of a petition and pursuit
to proceed under rule 11.
members we have a petition to be
presented this evening
and this will be presented by mr steve
tellis
who will have a total of five minutes to
present it
i'll call i'll call you in a second to
tell us
after that members we will have a total
of 15 minutes in which to debate the
petition
i will ask the portfolio holder for
housing assets and ledger councillor
webb to respond to the petition
in the first instance
and then invite members to contribute to
the debate
as we only have 15 minutes in total
i want as many members as possible to
have an opportunity to speak
i would like to move a motion without
notice
to reduce the speaking time
for each member to two minutes
for this item
do i have a second yes chairman thank
you
members
do i have have your agreement to that
show of hands those in favor
please go ahead those against
okay please lay your hand
any abstentions
okay okay members uh that's four 22
against three and three abstentions
okay mr telus
you now have the opportunity
at the
please come forward
if
just to advise you will have an
opportunity at the end of the debate to
sum up for the maximum of one minute
if you wish to do so
thank you chairman good evening
councillors
thank you for giving me
time to present
this petition from over 2 000 local
people
2024 to be exact both online and in hard
copy they all wanted to save both
mill hall and
civic suite with its gardens and council
debating chamber
this position has been a long time in
coming
it started back in 2021 but was
significantly delayed
by your purdue rules in early 2022.
since the
since the petition's inception
we know
council have dealt with some of the
aspects
that are
some of the aspects but there are some
key issues called for in the petition
that remain unaddressed
it is indeed unusual that i stand before
you now seeing all your pleasant faces
in this school hall
and i i do note your new layout which is
commendable
but normally like most residents i'm at
the back seeing only
the councillors from the back
nothing wrong in your backs i i must
hesitate to say but
that is the way is that really the way
to conduct a public debate on important
local issues
is it not ironic that you have an
historic custom-made debating chamber
with a public gallery microphones
and company seats
a mile away in the center of the biggest
town in our district
that light which lies empty
while you hire this hall for public
meetings
this is why
2024 taxpayers have petitioned to save
both mill hall and the council chamber
this is what they say
we the undersigned are opposed to the
sale and demolition of mill hall raleigh
and the sale of rayleigh civic suite
including the council chamber we hereby
petition rochford district council to
carry out a full public consultation on
the same on the sale of these publicly
owned buildings and to abide
by the results of that public
consultation
now
we recognize that the consultation since
the inception of the petition has in
fact happened
but it's this abiding bit that worries
us
especially regarding the civic suite
council chamber and gardens in raley's
conservation area
i hope you can give residents your
support
for the uh for saving these buildings
and this landscape in the future thank
you
thank you mrs please have a seat
counselor webb can i please invite you
to respond to the petition and you have
up to two minutes
thank you mr chairman
i reserve the right to comment at the
end of the debate
however i would like to propose the
motion that no further action is taken
thank you
the next speaker i have
is councillor wilkinson
hang on a second councillor wilson sorry
i need a seconder for that motion
i think council wouldn't had his hand up
first i think
thank you chairman i would like to
second that motion and if i may also
reserve my right to speak later in the
debate thank you thank you
councillor wilkinson sorry
thank you chair i hope i may able still
to say what i was going to say now that
we're now speaking to the motion that's
on the table um i i would like to just
address the um the fact that the the
issues to do with the civic suite have
made because obviously the mill hall has
been subject to discussions within the
executive the leader and i have had
another conversation about the civic
suite and i think he knows where i stand
on it and uh
i'm not
in support of the plans that we have
before us
what i would like to propose and i don't
know how as a council we could move this
foot going forward is um
we're in a bit of a quandary really
because um
we saw the last partnership panel
meeting and i hope i don't speak out a
term when i say this that the with the
price of material building materials
going in one direction
the price price for state not quite
reaching it the funding gap for the
freight house is growing as we speak and
it may get to the point where we can't
afford to do what we want to do at the
freight house so we need to keep a
backstop we need to keep something there
because what if we can't deal with use
the freight house then if we sell the
civic suite then we've lost our council
chamber and i wonder if at this time of
uncertainty whilst we go through the
process of dealing with the freight
house if we can press the pause button
on the civic suite thank you
council newport
again council newport you have two
minutes
thank you chairman
um giving the motion on on the table
i'll follow councillor wilson's lead
wilkinson's lead
with um not really speaking to the
motion um
firstly i feel it is right to thank
councillor woodson that for the
foreseeable i will never again have to
have so many photos taken outside one
building and finally the mill hall
will be returned to the community
and with a long sustainable plan
for its future in the pipeline
it will not have escaped your attention
that the residents of the district do
not like the changes that were planned
and rightly so rejected the plans of
this council to close the mill hall
but i do feel we must turn our attention
to the rejection of the planning
to their rejection of the planning
proposals for the housing
and offices at the civic suite
it goes
further than this though
rayleigh town council also outright
rejected the plans
although the planning permission has now
been granted for the development of
housing all is not yet lost
once we have the chance we should not be
dead set on a course of no return
unlike in other planning decisions in
this case
we do have a chance to seize the
opportunity and realize that we are the
masters of our residents destiny and
aren't at the mercy of developers
this council has a chance
to redeem itself and bring about some
common sense in its decision making
reopening the mill hall
is the first step in regaining the trust
that has been lost between elected
members and residents
but it is a baby step
does the leader not agree with me now it
is the time to stop wasting council
taxpayers money on hiring venues to hold
meetings and training sessions
when we do have a perfectly good
taxpayer-owned facility at our disposal
i would like to propose newport i'm
going to have to ask you can i just wrap
up one sentence as quickly as you can i
would like to propose that a full
socio-economic analysis is carried out
into reopening the civic suite and the
mata brought back to the next meeting of
the full council thank you chairman
any of anybody else
council sparring
thank you chairman
having been a resident of this town of
raleigh since the late 50s i'm very much
aware of the nostalgia that is attached
to this civic suite
unfortunately
it is requ surplus to the recounces
requirements these days
it is not the most suitable place to
conduct business in my view never has
been and i would point out as mr torres
point out sitting at the back here
you're looking at the back of our
councillors is exactly the same in the
civic suite
with regards to
other aspects i think we just come down
to sadly the situation of economics
we've looked the world has changed we've
covered all the rest of it
the council's structure has changed the
way we operate everybody has changed and
i'm afraid we have buildings now that
were built many many years ago have
served their time but now our surplus to
what the new council or the council
moving forward will need thank you
chairman
councillor mr mason
thank you
thank you chairman
i'd like to ask a question because a
number of speakers have spoken about
using
the civic suite again
whether
on a replacement basis
for public buildings could be currently
being used
or indeed is a backstop
i've heard various statements made that
the
the building has been stripped
all of the
benches and all of the
tables have been taken out of the
council chamber
i've had no one
able to tell me what the position is
if we're going to have proposals put
forward to reuse it again
then we need to know what condition it's
in so can offer can an officer tell me
chairman please
okay next person to speak
counselor sharp
thank you
mr chair
i'd just like to uh express a view as to
the
scope
of the
socio-economic survey that uh
anal or analysis that uh councillor
newport
recommended
i think it should certainly include an
analysis of the financials
that is the
cost of potential income
of retaining the civic suite as against
the total expenditures
and income that could be derived from
retaining the current plan
but i think it should also look at the
impact on the community
and on the existing users of the
facility
and other potential users because as
as it has been remarked it does have the
facilities although there may be some
issue on the condition of those
facilities they're there and they can be
used
thank you
okay
councillor mrs rowe
thank you chairman um
it would be helpful if the monitoring
officer could set out the options open
to us under the constitution
i'll let everybody speak and then uh
i'll ask the question
sorry i can see your hand
sorry counselor mrs mason sorry
thank you chair
the residents have made their views well
known it is sad that the divide between
residents and the council remains so
wide
the closure of the mill hall is
understanding abayas
but the civic suite should be
reconsidered and to reconsider that
fully
i would appreciate it and i'm sure
councilman masonwood if someone could
answer his question as to the state of
the civic suite because otherwise we are
debating
without full knowledge
so can someone please answer that
question before the debate continues
thank you
other speakers
okay is there any other speakers
okay i'll come back to you councilwoman
council constable
thank you chairman um can you turn your
mic just a little bit absolute picture
can i just uh remind members although
rayleigh is one of the largest towns in
the area it's not the center of
rochefort district council
rochford town is actually more central
to rochford it's also served by
a railway station that is adjacent to it
and several bus routes and it is a more
central point in the area whereas
rayleigh isn't and
two thousand petition people on a
petition when we've got over 80 000
people in the district isn't a good
representation thank you
did you want to come back when you when
you speak at the end of the debate
council stanley
thank you chairman i'd just like to
point out the railey hazard railway
station also has the main bus routes
into rayleigh and it's rainy residents
where the mill hall is
and not in rochford thank you and it's
central to rayleigh thank you very much
council myers
short little speech really um i was
elected in may 2001 and have yet to see
the inside of the council chamber but
every person i've spoken to has said is
not fit for purpose it's too small too
dark it's not you can't get if everybody
turns up nobody can get into the
building
sentiment has to go by the side and the
economic economics must take over and if
it needs to be sold because it's no good
then it has to go
that's my point chairman
councillor
thank you chairman
um just briefly i believe there was a
motion that he put forward and seconded
if that was the case can that be
repeated please
um
and
and
i'll just leave that there i just want
to know what the motion is if there was
one pull forward
there was and uh we'll come to that in a
second or two does anybody else wish to
speak
emotion what can i i didn't hear the
motion clearly if it was put forward i
may have a question if i understood what
the motion was thank you
the motion was that no further action
should be taken
it's a bit of an open
motion isn't it but what does that mean
that we
it's
no further action is taken in relation
to the petition
or
to the civic suite or the mill hall
thank you
i'll let the officer just answer those
couple of questions
chairman thank you his assists um
under um
the council's constitution
um the response to petitions following
debate uh has a finite number of
potential options
um option uh four is uh to take the
action requ sorry number one is to take
the action requested in the petition as
drafted
option two is not taking the action
requested for reasons put forward in the
debate
option three is commissioning further
investigation into the matter or option
four deciding whether to make
recommendations where the matter falls
to the executive to make the final
decision
so members the last option there does
not apply because this is a meeting of
full council and the decision is for you
for you
so therefore the option options are to
do what is requested by the petitioner
not to take any further action or to
commission further investigation those
are the options members okay
thank you
okay i've got just enough time for one
more speaker before we sum up
thank you chairman uh i would like to
thank mr telus for the presentation of
the
uh petition this evening and for his
patience in presenting it to us um
i
would like to point out that he referred
to the fact that there are 2024
signatures and i have absolutely no
doubt very genuine in their wishes and
the wording of this motion
but there are 85 000 residents of this
district uh 50 000 or so live in the
radi immediate rady area
and i have to say and again i respect
the fact it's a bit of a dated motion
but there have been two public
consultations one with the asset
delivery program itself and one with the
planning proposals so it has been out to
public consultation
there was never ever any intention to
sell the mill hall um that
the plan the original plan which there's
been a lot of ground covered since was
to actually provide radio with a brand
new community center albeit on a
different footprint i realize that is
now history and i am committed to
providing a fine uh community centre uh
in uh in raleigh in a refurbished mill
hall for the reasons i've set out an
executive
a month or so ago
in terms of the civic suite chairman
i think as an obligation as a council we
have to look at redundant and surplus
buildings and it is no longer needed
it is as simple as that and in any good
housekeepers purse we have to look at
the pennies the simple fact is the civic
suite is not functional
i'm not quite sure where the comfy seats
comes from because i've never sat on a
comfy seat there
they are pretty impressive to look at
but certainly not particularly
comfortable
to sit on for too long
i've had the benefit of looking at the
constitution and
that is my chairman i come to the
conclusion that with the greatest of
respect to mr tellis and the signatures
on the
petition i come to the conclusion that
in practical terms on the wording of
this motion
there is no further if you would sum up
now please thank you very much indeed
chairman i've said all i wish to say
thank you
members just before i get councillor
webb to um
restate his motion can you just ask the
question on that was asked about the
furniture please
thank you chair
yes my understanding is that the because
the building is vacant um office
furniture so desks and chairs and and
which would be used by officers has been
removed
um and that would be perfectly normal
for
insurance purposes and for fire risk
purposes but the chamber remains intact
thank you chair thank you
council webb can you
represent your motion please thank you
chairman
i have listened closely to the debate
tonight and clearly we have no intention
of selling the mill hall in fact we have
agreed to reopen it and not just in the
daytime but during the evening and
weekends as well
where the civic suite is concerned a
decision will be made in accordance with
due process at a later date at paul
council where a stop go decision will be
taken
therefore these reasons i propose that
no further action is taken thank you
mr tellis
you have the opportunity
to
have one minute to say anything further
if you so wish
thank you a very interesting debate um
i would emphasize whilst there were 2024
signatures on this particular petition
your own consultation
your own engagement consultation
actually showed that almost 90 percent
of those respondents wanted to save the
civic suite
almost 90 percent so really what you're
saying is our consultation went out
we're ignoring 90 of the respondents so
i'm quite disappointed by that
um i note what your
your emotion and uh also
um
councillor newport was seeking to do a
motion i would hope that that would
still be
available to the council
should
should the opportunity arise thank you
very much
thank you
members we have a motion moved by
councillor webb and seconded by
councillor wooden
we will now vote on the motion
okay okay thank you
okay if you can speak clearly when sonia
calls your name please
counselor mrs belton
councillor mrs butcher
four
councillor mr carter
against
[Music]
gadsden
councillor hoy
against
counselor lamborn
against
councillor mrs mason
against
councillor mr mason again
counselor mrs mcpherson
councillor milne
four
councillor myers
council mr newport
against
council lisa newport
councillor mrs rowe
councillor sharp
against
councillor mrs shaw
councillor mrs squires coleman against
councillor spelling
councillor wilkinson against
councillor wilson william sorry
or
councillor
mr wilson
against
cancer mrs wilson again
councillor whatton
four
18 for the motion
15 against the motion
so the motion is carried
mr telus
you will receive a written copy of the
council's response
to your petition and a copy will also be
uploaded on the council's website
mr telus and any other members of the
public you're more than welcome to stay
for the remaining of the of the business
but if you like to leave please do so
through the door
to my right
and make your way to the car park
i'd like to thank telus for coming
forward and bringing the petition
and
taking the opportunity to stand to speak
thank you members that concludes that
item of business
i will now turn to item six of the
agenda
members item six the appointment of
directors to the council
council local authority trading
companies
the report will be presented by the
council strategic director angela
hutchins
thank you members um the report before
you arises for appointment of
the council's local authority trading
companies the council is the shareholder
of a number of local authority trading
companies in accordance with the
relevant legislation
the
right therefore
to appoint directors to those accounts
to those companies lies with council and
therefore members you're asked to make
the recommendations that are set out in
paragraph 12. thank you
do we have any speakers on this item
counselor
yes um it's a a question
i was uh originally involved in the
setting up of the black hose some years
ago and the advice
we received then was that counselors
wouldn't normally be appointed as
directors to these companies
can i just ask why that advice has now
changed thank you why she was changed
thank you council ahoy
in relation to the
rochford north limited um that is a
joint venture company with a another
entity as a consequence of the articles
of association of that company um it's
that as it says in paragraph 6.3 no
resolution can be passed unless it's
agreed by at least one council appointed
director the control therefore of the
council in respect of that joint venture
should properly sit with a councillor
under those very particular
circumstances
okay
question it was
or maybe i didn't work the question very
well said
effectively i'm saying why are we
appointing a counsellor
because the vice president previously
has been not two so the previous uh so
all the other local authority training
companies the council is 100
shareholder and therefore the um role of
the council is as shareholder rather
than as director of the company in
relation to the joint venture
the council itself is also is therefore
not the sole shareholder and under the
rules of the local authority training
companies actually a minority
shareholder therefore it's important for
the council to have representation at
board level and that's why a councillor
is appointed as a director
anybody else wish to speak council in
newport
thank you chairman um
i think it might have been of some
benefit to explain exactly what these uh
limited companies are for
because i for one don't know what the
green gateway trading development
limited company actually does
and it might have been beneficial for
newer members could um officers briefly
explain please
thank you councillor newport um you may
remember it certainly it's a decision of
this council which predates me
that the council
set up a group of limited local
authority trading companies of which
screen gateway trading limited is the
parent company or the holding company
green gateway trading gm limited and
green gateway trading development
limited are subsidiaries of that holding
company so the shareholder for each of
those is in fact the whole company and
green gateway trading limited the idea
behind setting up those
trading companies in the first instance
was to allow the council the opportunity
to deliver its
grounds maintenance contracts
both as an arms length company but also
to other public sector bodies
and for the trading development company
at the time was around the potential for
the council to undertake um housing
development under its own steam given
that the council no longer has a housing
revenue account the only way that the
council can legitimately build houses is
through an arms-length local authority
trading company
the circumstances are such however that
green gateway trading development
limited has never traded and remains um
therefore untrading uh green gateway
trading limited exists purely as i say
as a holding company and has conducts no
business on its own terms and green
gateway trading gm limited the grounds
maintenance contract came to a cease to
trade when the service was brought back
in house in december of last year
the
norse joint venture company is a
consequence of the uh agreement by this
council to enter into a joint venture
with norse commercial services limited
and the joint venture company between
those two organized between that
organization and the council is the
delivery vehicle for the council's waste
contract
council newport did you want to come
back
yes thank you chairman sorry i think i
missed a bit about well maybe i didn't
on the development but since these are
dormant companies wouldn't it just be
easier to wind them up
thank you council newport um that is
certainly an option uh winding up
companies however is a uh somewhat
complicated um process when the council
is a shareholder it's intended that a
report will be brought back to the
council in the autumn in order to give
the council the option to wind up
companies which are no longer trading um
however the council may decide to uh to
to keep them and therefore preserve the
lane because there are pros and cons
associated with winding up the uh the
companies and particularly a company
which has only recently ceased to um
operate
this decision has been brought forward
simply because of the vacancies arising
through the departure of myself and
other colleagues from the uh from the
council thank you
councillors
i do understand what um angela just
brought to us but a member's liquidation
isn't that complicated i don't
understand why we're going through all
the
uh rigmarole of keeping these companies
going where they have no purpose and
there is no seeming reason for them
nothing coming up this vacancy on any
agenda anywhere it just seems completely
pointless
so thank you councillors with respect i
think that is a decision for council to
make in the fullness of time um the
future use of the trading companies or
not is a matter for the council to be to
to decide the winding up is necessary
because when a company has been uh in
operation at least six months needs to
pass before the company can be
legitimately wound up there are
insurance
reasons for keeping the
company for winding the companies up but
equally
if a company is wound up then it loses
its name and the council loses its
proprietary interest in intellectual
property in the name green gateway
trading and so that's a decision for
council which will be brought back in
the autumn
okay
councillor sharp um when you indicate
can you please make sure it's nice and
positive we weren't sure if you were
indicated or not
oh thank you chair i just want to ask
whether the directorship is a paid
position
uh thank you councillor sharp no they
are not
thank you
council award
thank you chairman
i fully understand the position has laid
down in this document it's purely a case
and it's very common to make companies
which have a trademark and are trading
they have traded to make them dormant
and then and then at a later time if the
opportunity
arises they can be reactivated quite
easily so i fully agree with what has
been done thus far thank you chairman
just checking anybody else
nobody is indicating okay thank you
members there are three recommendations
set out in paragraph 12.1 of the report
on pages 6.2 and 6.3
i remove them from the chair
i'll read them through to appoint marcus
hotten as director of green gateway
trading limited
to to appoint marcus hotten as director
of green gateway trading development in
brackets limited
three to appoint councillor david
sperring and cal and steve summers as
directors of the rochford north limited
are you happy for me to take the three
recommendations on block
i will assume agreement unless you raise
your hand
okay thank you
so members
those in favor please indicate
please know your hands
those against
okay
are there any abstentions
members
that is
that's 34
against zero
and three abstentions
rivers that motion is carried
members
item 7 of the agenda
appointment of the joint strategic
directors
uh the report were presented by the
council strategic director angela
hutchins
thank you chair members this is a report
to confirm the appointment of tier two
strategic directors for the brentwood
borough council and rochford district
council one team these are joint
appointments which will serve both
councils in accordance with the
one team transformation programme a
report in identical terms will go to the
brentwood borough council full council
evening tomorrow evening
statutory guidance under section 40 of
the localism act 2011 requires that full
council or some other agreed formal
meeting of members should be offered the
opportunity to approve salary packages
over 100 000 pounds
and members therefore i invite you to
approve the recommendations set out in
paragraph 9.
members uh there is a confidential
appendix to this report
if you need to refer to this or ask a
question on this
can you please raise your hand now
as it will be necessary to exclude the
press and the public first
nobody's indicating okay thank you
does anybody wish to speak on this
thank you chairman
item 8 on page 7.3
apparently we've not completed equality
impact assessment
there's no relevant decisions being
taken i would beg to disagree as i do
quite often with this
at this point in our agenda
um
i would i would hope
a relevant decision is being made we're
appointing people to
director roles surely within the
recruitment process
we made sure that the this was fair
under the equality diversity act can you
confirm that was the case if it if we
well it should at least be mentioned in
point a i think we had this discussion
at the last meeting where we're failing
to use this part of the agenda properly
we're not stating
how we are looking at equality and
diversity implications
we're just taking it as read that we've
done it somewhere within our policies we
should be stating the policies where
this is this is looked at when we are
doing the appointments like these
and it's not done can you confirm that
has been done please
do you wish to come
thank you chair thank you council lahoy
yes i can confirm that an equality
impact assessment was undertaken as part
of the restructure process
the um
in terms of this report the dis
equality impact assessment relates to
the decision that's being taken and the
decision therefore is to appoint
as racist to confirm the appointment the
appointment having already been made by
the relevant uh committee so um so that
is why there is no relevant decision for
the purposes of the eqia but i can of
course confirm that the appointments
were undertaken in accordance with all
hr policies for both councils
and indeed in the light of the pay
policy statement approved by this
council in june of this
year okay uh next on my list is
counselor mrs mason
thank you chair um
i'm going to counsel mr mason can you
move the mic just a little closer
i can indeed thank you
right
um
i'm going to move to
a query on the recommendation you'll be
pleased i'm sure to hear that i've got
no
issue with recommendation one and i'm
sure that
most of us here will support that
however
um
recommendation two creates a problem
previous council decision
very clearly was that any changes to the
constitution
were checked by the standards committee
before changes were implemented
even when they were minor changes of a
name change
the reasons for these were amongst other
things but but they basically were
two-fold
one
was to prevent errors
and secondly to add member involvement
to a critical council
document can i ask why and what are the
reasons that we were departing from a
previous council decision
thank you
thank you council mrs mason i'm not
aware of that previous decision and
certainly this recommendation has
appeared in uh several reports um in in
identical terms um so it's not a it's
not a new recommendation um i hear what
you say in relation to the ability of
this council to ask for um
changes to be checked by the uh
standards committee it's the fact that
in the constitution changes um to the
constitution lie with full council so it
is a matter for council to decide
whether to delegate those as is
suggested by a second recommendation to
the monitoring officer in consultation
with the portfolio holder for governance
or to indeed delegate them to another
body um and
members uh that is of course a matter
for you
thank you mr chairman yeah i can only
apologize that i didn't pick up this
error before um but i have picked it up
and the reason that decision was made by
the council was because it changed the
constitution was affected i was hoping
not to have to say this in book council
with because the change of the
constitution was implemented which was
impossible for members to actually carry
out and it took six months for that to
be corrected and that's why that change
was made i'm not sure that it's ever
been enacted because i'm not on the
standards committee and haven't been
recently but it is a matter of concern
that there should be some sort of
backstop to any changes thank you
right next to my list is councillor mrs
shaw
okay
and then we go to council newport
thank you chairman um just a point of
clarification on
page
7.2
as the end is the first line on that
page emily ill appointed on the 14th of
july who will be employed on the
blank council's establishment
could uh officers clarify whose
establishment should be employed on
please
thank you councillor newport it isn't a
blank it's just the line spacing of the
formatting it reads will be employed on
the council's establishment ie watch for
district council
thank you
any other speakers
nobody else is indicating okay
uh thank you very much chair
mrs wilson can you just turn the mic so
it points out towards you is that better
thank you lovely thank you chair i'd
just like to go back to the point of the
uh equality and diversity um impact
assessments made by my colleague council
ahoy
i have previous experience of these and
i've always found in the past that
actually it's helpful to say when the
consideration of the equality impact
assessment
was considered even if it was deemed not
or relevant to that point i do think
that that would be helpful going forward
that's it chairman thank you
thank you mr wilson i think that point
is noted when officers have made a note
of that
anybody
that's lefty
thank you chairman just a quick tester
i'm sorry
thank you chairman just a quick question
where it says uh steve summers and ian
winslet will be
uh
brentwood bower council is it uh will be
employed by rochford where it says the
council
that's that's correct
okay
anybody else
quickly okay
members there are two recommendations
set out on page 7.4 of the report at
paragraph
9.1
recommendation one to appoint the street
director for the council and brentwood
borough council has set out in the
confidential appendix
excluding
two that the monitor officer be giving
delegated authority in consultation with
the portfolio holder for governance to
make the
required changes to the constitution
to give effect to the recommendations in
this report
i will remove these recommendations from
the chair do i have a secondary
council
council thank you
members are you happy to take these
recommendations on block
if you are not pleasing
council mrs mason
okay thank you
okay we'll take them as separate items
then
okay recommendation one
uh to appoint the strategic director for
the council and brentwood council has
set out in the confidential appendix
those in favor
[Music]
please know your hands
those against
okay
that's unanimous thank you
okay recommendation two
that the monitoring officer be giving
delegated authority in consultation with
the portfolio holder for governance
to make any required changes to the
constitution
to give
effect to the recommendation in this
report
goes in favor
close your hands
those against
and are there any abstentions
okay
um item 2 that's
19 4
13 against and one abstention
that is carried
okay
okay
uh members moving on to item eight
reports from the executive and
committees to the council
8.181
report of the executive
advice service contracts 2022-2024
council williams portfolio holder for
communities and health will introduce
the report
councillor
williams
thank you chairman
members
we're being asked to agree the outcome
of the advice services
tender and award the advice services
contract
22 24 to citizen advice south essex i
should refer to them
as case
yeah to save time for that further right
in my
mind my speech thank you the councils
the council has for a number of years
tendered and awarded an advisory
services contract
that our residents have come to rely on
for free general support and independent
advice
case has proven over previous contracts
to be a partner
who have delivered a good level of
service
only last quarter case managed 814
inquiries
an increase of 150 inquiries
and those demands for support were
particularly in relation to debt housing
money advice employment
and relationship and family issues
whilst the cost of living remains
challenging for us all it is more
important than ever
to support the ongoing provision of a
free advisory
and prevention service such as provided
by case
any reductions in provision would
inevitably impact adversely on the
well-being of our residents
funding the general advice service
provides support that can help residents
prevent an escalation of health care
and associate and housing needs which in
turn reduces the likelihood of them
requiring more intensive and costly
support in a crisis
this year's tender contract is for two
years
with the option for the council to
extend the contract for a further one
year
the value of this contract is seventy
thousand pounds per year
only on evaluation the ten of the tender
process case met all the requirements of
the specification
and hence we are recommending that case
should be awarded the advice services
contract
for years 22 24
in light of all the benefit it brings to
our residents and council
thank you
members everybody wish
that was new paul
hey chairman um
i wholeheartedly uh
support this
um the one thing that i would raise
um within this report which i'm a little
bit disappointed to read
is that the uh
council accommodation at back lane
well residents that hard up and can't
afford a train ticket or catch a bus
they need to get access to the service
face-to-face in rayleigh
so
i will ask the portfolio holder value
chair
if we can negotiate that with case to
and find them a space available in
rayleigh so residents can access the
service i've referred three people to
case this week so
it's a really valuable service that i'm
sure with the cost of living crisis well
underway would be very valued thank you
councillor williams do you wish to
respond to that
councillor
um
i'm sorry
newports i do apologize um as far as i'm
aware the civic suite is open the the
front desk is open and it's being used
by
by the citizens of vice peer at the
moment
okay uh councilwoman
if at all i've just got a few questions
about how we monitor the service i was
interested to hear some figures from
council william just said about how many
people use it i think it was the last
ball
the microphones aren't perfect tonight
for my ears
um
can you can it be confirmed that we do
set targets for case
do we
how do we monitor them do we
is there a satisfaction survey done of
customers who see it see them
um
how do we monitor the quality and
diversity side of it in particular which
is in the report and can please see
how do we perform how do they perform
against targets in previous years
i just want to get an understanding of
how much
value our residents get
out of the 70 000 pounds and
what level of service they would have
without it as well i just want to know
how that's monitored is there is there a
system in place can they be grateful for
a response thank you
council williams thank you councillor um
i would have to come back to you that
and
come back with some more information for
you
yeah i'd be grateful if you would do
your counsellors please thank you
thank you
okay
council refti
thank you chairman just a quick question
um business council a few years
many years this comes around which is a
great service every year it's 70 grand
i think 70 grand in the past has been
the right sort of money but with costly
inflation we're actually getting less
for that 70 000 pound so i know it's too
late for this year but for next year
could be looking
maybe putting this up a little bit with
cost inflation
castle williams did you want to respond
to that at all
not at this time thank you chairman
apart from the fact that as um this is
the sub that's
been asked for
thank you
council wilkinson
um councillor ft actually maybe
inadvertently answered my question
because um uh i i wholeheartedly support
this night no doubt that case provided
an excellent service the thing that
concerns me from this report is that
there was only one bid
um and i i think it's quite unusual to
get one bid and i was going to ask why
and it might be because the the level
the the value of the contract i don't
know
i'll leave that as a question but it
does concern me we're only getting one
bid and how can we measure
properly the service we're providing for
the residents i know we can look at
cases are they doing the right thing but
we don't know what else is out there and
i'm just a bit concerned we're only
getting one bid really i don't know why
we're only getting one bit it's unusual
thank you
williams
thank you councillor wilkinson um
every year it goes out to
tender and every year we only ever get
one back in so
like you i would also wonder the same
but um i'll make some inquiries and come
back to you also
thank you
nobody else is interested okay anybody
else know
okay
okay members there's one recommendation
to set out at paragraph
1.2
on page 8.11
of the report
to agree
the outcome of the
advice service services tender and award
the advice service services contract
2022 to 2024 to the citizens advice
essex case in brackets
i'll remove that from the
chair if any can i have a second or for
that please i'm happy to second that
chair thank you
members
all those in favor please indicate
thank you members that's unanimous
members item
eight
two
uh the report of the executive asset
delivery program update
council web portfolio holder
holder for housing
assets and leisure will introduce the
report
council web
thank you chairman this item of business
was referred by the executive on 13th of
july 2022 to council with a
recommendation on the asset delivery
programme update the report to the
executive is attached in appendix one
i'm pleased to say that the executive
unanimously agreed option three in the
report which was to reopen the mill hall
and further recommends to council that
the additions to the 22
23 capital programme would support the
costs associated with the refurbishment
of the mill hall arts and event center
to ensure a successful relaunch of the
site in september 22.
the two recommendations from the exec
from this executive meeting that needs
to come before council tonight
are outlined below on
8.21 and they are
to agree the additions to the 22-23
capital program of 6250 pounds for the
compliance and essential maintenance
works required to reopen the freight
house to be funded from the general
balance and secondly to agree additions
to the 22-23 capital programme of 40 000
pounds for compliance and essential
maintenance works prior to the reopening
of the mill arts and event centre the
costs will be funded from the general
fund balances thank you are you moving
those recommendations council i'm moving
those yes thank you do you have a
seconder
okay
counselor mr shaw thank you
uh right we have first speaker on this
council wilkinson
thank you councillor webb and um i think
we're all happy and um pleased to see
the middle hall opening again i've just
got one question regarding the 40 000
pounds for me um
obviously one thing we did discover
within the partnership panel that we
what we didn't know the cost of
refurbishment the building was but it's
a very unknown quantity so i wonder
where the 40 000 figures come from what
you're hoping to achieve with that and i
know moving forward you're looking for
bids of interest for community uh groups
to move in there so
how do you see
the refurbishment program moving forward
because i would imagine the forty
thousand pounds not it i wouldn't have
thought that's anywhere near enough but
i'm just sort of guessing a bit really
thank you
guys do you want to respond to that
thank you council wilkinson yes i'm
pleased that we are opening the mail
hall as well it will be good for the
town good for the district in terms of
the breakdown of those figures that
outlined in 16.7 within the report that
gives you the breakdown of the works
that will be needed
to reopen the mill hall in terms of the
compliance and remedial works that will
cost a total of twenty thousand pounds
the maintenance um
for the opening which will cost seventy
thousand pounds and within that the
capital costs are part of that if you
wanted a further breakdown of those
costs then i would need to ask the
assistant director matt hold white for
that information
um in terms of before we open in
september there will be a light touch
refurb to the mill hall carried out and
then we'll be looking to continue
further works the mill horse in the to
the mill hall in the fullness of time
thank you
okay
any other speakers
okay thank you thank you members there
are two recommendations which i will
take separately
as set out in paragraph 1.5
on page 8.2.1
of the report
okay first recommendation as i say i'll
take these separately
to agree
additions to the
2022-23 capital program
of
6250 pound for compliance and essential
maintenance works required to the
reopening of the freight house to be
funded from general balances
members those in favor
members that's unanimous
sorry for council lefty
let me make a note of that thank you
okay
item two
the additions to the
2022-23 capital program of 40 000 pound
for compliance and essential maintenance
works prior to reopening the middle hall
the mill arts and events center
the cost will be funded from the general
fund balances
those in favor
those against
any abstentions
okay
that's 32 4
none against no abstentions
within across the church
um you'll have to excuse my colleague
council stanley he's had to leave he's
in a lot of agony pain at the moment so
could you please
could we just have a slight pause so i
can just check on him yes certainly
that's not thank you
i'll suspend for five minutes thank you
yes
it is quite warm in here so if you wish
to take your jackets off
please feel
feel free to do so
which is quite warm
and i do notice that a number of members
have suddenly suddenly found a raid of
biscuits
if we were in our council chamber that
wouldn't be allowed so
so i'm not going to mention it but
actually chairman some are on their
double dose of this yes yeah so we're
we're not looking at anybody
um
okay
okay members right let's move on
uh item eight three
uh review committee annual report
councillor wilson will chairman of the
overview and scrutiny committee will
introduce the report council wilson
thank you chairman thank you for
inviting us to take our jackets off
unfortunately i only
eye in the front of my shirt
i think they call that a dicky
councillor
um
members in front of you you've got the
annual report form for what was called
previously the review committee i'd like
to thank all of the members of the
committee
last year and the officers for their
help and support during the year
and also in particular thanks to the
vice chair who does a lot of unseen work
behind the scenes so thank you
last year the committee was audited by
the center for governance and scrutiny
we've implemented a number of those
recommendations during the year and
we're actually going to review ourselves
on our progress later this year
and we're obviously looking to make
continual improvements
the committee is now looking much more
at pre-scrutiny so in the past we've
been quite a backward-looking committee
which actually doesn't really add much
value so we've now started to do
pre-scrutiny
and the idea is that we influence
policy and decisions and we also provide
robust assurance to members of the
executive
we undertook our first pre-scrutiny in
january which was the rockford district
council and brentwood borough council
partnership and as an exercise i think
percy that that went very well so thank
you all the members
so i commend the report to members and
i'm happy to take any questions chair
members are there any questions you wish
council wouldn't
thank you chairman i would like to take
this opportunity of congratulating
councillor stuart wilson um under his
stewardship for the way he has steered
the review and laterally overview and
scrutiny in this council and i think
together with his members and he has
actually made that
a much more constructive and positive
process because it is right and proper
that
decisions made by the administration are
held to account and that is the due
process for doing it and equally i think
it is absolutely right that there is an
opportunity for pre-scrutiny which is a
fairly new process for us here in
rochford and i think already it is
proving uh major benefits um so
well done uh thank you very much indeed
for your report i will finish with a
question um
there's a very shade of grey version in
my report here
but where does the uh
the report actually end up because it
would be nice to think that uh it
receives wider publication uh possibly
in some sort of better format than uh
shades of grey in this report i really
do think that we actually ought to be
you know singing from the rooftops the
good work that the uh
overview and scrutiny committee is doing
thank you chairman
our
members i stand corrected by officers
and council wilson but i believe that
will be
documented on the website
there's a color version of it
okay any other questions
okay members do you receive the
annual report of the review committee
2021 stroke 22.
thank you
item 8-4 treasury management annual
review
2021 stroke 22
council wilson chairman of the overview
and scrutiny committee will introduce
the report
chairman the um the treasury management
annual review 2021 22 report is a
factual report so it actually gives a
statement of activities that were
undertaken during that municipal year
the overview and scrutiny review
committee have reviewed the report and
we've made no major
observations or recommendations
so i therefore commend the report to
members and
i'm less than happy to take questions on
technical details
members are there any questions
council ahoy
justin
ask why there are no equality and
diversity implications
on this report there is no mention of it
even i can understand it might be none
but there's no mention of it so it's not
even being considered according to the
report
council wilson do you wish to comment on
that or shall we just officers will note
that and uh take it away for the next
report obviously
um thank you chairman yeah i think it
would be better to note it and take it
away but what i would ask is if we could
put it in for next year's report maybe
thank you
officers will make a note of that i'm
sure
any other questions
okay
members the contents of the treasury
management annual report 2021 22 do you
note it
thank you members
item 8 5
the new local government association
model code of conduct
chairman of the standards committee
council mcpherson
will introduce the report councilman
thank you chairman
with the new code of conduct being
written in the first person it is hoped
that councillors will take a stronger
more personal approach to ensure their
actions meet those expected of the
councillor
it aims to build
on the seven principles of public life
self selflessness
integrity
objectivity accountability
openness honesty and leadership
the new code now includes a definition
of respect
also the term bullying is a new addition
to the code
i will draw your attention to page
8.5.10
of the report
respect
means politeness and courtesy in
behavior speech and in the written word
debate in having different views are all
part of a healthy democracy
as a counselor you can express challenge
criticize and disagree
with views ideas opinions and policies
in a robust
but civil matter manner sorry
you should not however
subject individuals groups of people or
organizations to personal attack
bullying the code refers to the advisory
conciliation and arbitration service
acres
characteristics bullying as offensive
intimidating malicious or insulting
behaviour
an abuse or misuse of power through
means that undermine
humiliate
denigrate or injure the recipient
bullying might be a regular pattern of
behaviour or one-off incident
it could happen face to face on social
media in emails or on phone calls
it can happen in the workplace or at
work social events and may not always be
obvious or noticed by others
please remember it can even be indirect
such as simply liking a post
on social media that is aimed at another
person
so let us be honest
in politics we may come from polar
positions
but being respectful to each other
can close divisions
enhance cooperation and build
collaboration
each and every counsellor
should be able to undertake their role
without the fear of being bullied or
ridiculed
in essence through mutual politeness
respect and kindness
we will aid debate
listen better
to each other and work more
collaboratively
to serve our residents
with this in mind i put forward an
additional recommendation of the
standards meeting
which i am pleased to say was seconded
by councillor mike wilkinson lead of the
independent party
it reads
that leaders of all parties collectively
pledge to uphold the new code of conduct
within their parties and members
in addition
to encourage any candidates and
campaigners to embrace the nolan
principles
i hope all members will support both
recommendations
together we can create an environment
which encourages others to want to give
their time as a counsellor
thank you members
[Applause]
is there any questions members
counsel
clearly there's a number of councils
around essex at the moment and
councillor wilkin um
sorry councillor steptoe would be aware
of this because this came up with essex
as well
of an attempt to try and
get
some all councillors councils to try and
adopt the same um
model code of conduct
um
i have no problem with this and i fully
support that no problem at all i
absolutely agree with everything um
council mcpherson just said i've got no
problem with that
i i
i understand what you have said about
the the additional 0.1 on there i just
feel that as a counselor
i'm upholding the constitution anyway i
don't need a group leader to pledge it
for me i do it myself by being a
counsellor and by standing as a
counselor i accept those
the model code
i just think it's superfluous i think
it's a nice statement to make but i
don't i think everyone in this room
personally
are committed to uphold
the code of conduct as it stands
and it won't stop me voting for it at
all but i just wanted to make that
statement i think we all everyone here
agrees to the statement you've made
and i just think it's superfluous but
i'm happy to vote for it either way
thank you
council mcpherson do you wish to come
back on it thank you chairman
councillor
all very good points and i'm so pleased
that you support it
i want us to pledge
make that pledge to strengthen the code
of conduct
to make sure that we are all fully
supportive of what it means
most of us i think all of us in this
room are but we can then take that
forward
and when new candidates come forward
we're setting a precedent of this is how
we will behave
thank you chairman
um
it states the account that group leaders
are collectively pledging are they
gathering to physically pledge in a
place on the first day of a council
meeting or is it a a place that happens
automatically once they're a group
leader
i want to know the practicalities as
well thank you
councilman thank you chairman um
actually um uh
the vice chair of standards and
councillor mr wilkinson would you like
to comment on this
council wilkinson
thank you chair uh thank you councilman
mcpherson um
yeah i mean i understand exactly where
councillor is coming from because he's
right i mean the the whole purpose of
this is actually this is written in the
first person and so we all have a um a
duty the reason why i supported this
in the standards committee and the
reason why i support this now
um is and it's a slightly moot point for
the independent group with only been two
of us but it's a it's completely
different group
completely different point for the size
of the other um groups within here but
actually as a group leader you are
responsible for the behavior ultimately
of
of your members and you should be
encouraging good behavior amongst your
membership and particularly if you're
looking for new candidates um because of
the group leader you should be
explaining to the candidates what's
expected of them um and i think really
well what we were trying to say was that
you know
rather than all 39 members standing in a
big parade somewhere saying yeah we
support this the four group leaders only
four of us and we say yes on behalf of
our groups yes we pledge this and we
will uphold them because ultimately and
i think i'm correct in saying this if if
a standards complaint is upheld um and
it can be i think that it comes back to
a group leader to deal with it and so
you have to have some degree of sort of
authority over your group members uh in
that sense like i said it's a moot point
for my group because only myself and the
father-in-law so we're not going to do
that but i think for the slightly larger
groups in here it might be more relevant
but that's where we're coming from
councilwood
thank you chairman i've listened to the
points that have been made and actually
the more i've listened to the points the
more i think the
recommendation there
or the adoption
isn't the right wording
because it's not actually about being
encouraged it's about being required
so i would personally replace the word
with encouraged to require it
and then that strengthens
the the statement
others may have different wording and
then when i start looking at the point
that councillor hoi made councillor
wilkinson
i agree that group leaders do have a
responsibility to maintain discipline
order respect all the standards of
courtesy that we would expect but
actually group leaders can't enforce it
so there has to be some balance where
group leaders certainly have a
responsibility totally support but
actually i think there needs to be a
pledge by members as well in there and i
can't think immediately of the wording
off hand but actually i think there
should be a strengthening of the point
rather than a dilution of it and as i'm
reading it i'm sort of thinking
it's a bit
it's well intended known in no way
critical but i would like to see a
strengthening of it
and would welcome further debate on it
if others might have some suitable
wording
i think in public life now public life
can at times be a bit of a thankless
task
because i think some standards outside
of the 39 councillors are very much
wanting but we do have control within
our own uh set up
what people outside
our life do i'm afraid we have to manage
but i think it's all about dignity
respect making our points but respecting
the points that are made with that i'll
sit down chairman and throw it open
thank you castle wooden um can i just
ask a question uh of sonya here
when we are elected as councillors we
are we ask to sign
the book
is that what
that's what we sign isn't it to a pledge
to uphold
legally there is no requirement to uh to
to actually um
sorry
legally there is no requirement to uh to
to actually pledge to uh to uphold the
uh the code of conduct when you when you
become a new councillor
however we do ask our members to uh when
they when they sign the book they they
they all declare that they will sort of
uphold the the the model code of conduct
conduct that is something that uh that
we have done for for many years here at
rochester district council
does that cover your point councilwoman
well it does chairman to an extent
there's an awful lot of things in life
that aren't actually illegal but it's
about considerateness courtesy um and i
don't think we need a law to understand
what good courtesy and standards are
so i take the point
from the principal democratic services
officer
understand that but i still think it's
about setting a standard
and it's a little bit like dare i say
planning where we have standards on
certain things that we
would like to see in planning in the
district which aren't necessarily set
out in the national codes i think it's
about
actually us setting ourselves apart and
proving that rocha district council is
just a cut above the rest thank you
council
sonia thank you
okay
counselor mrs mason
thank you i must admit i think i agree
with kelsey woodson
that we we've saying the first person
then we're putting it in the third
person and this reads that the group
leaders i've got no problem with
pledging to do my best but
it takes it away from the individual
so um
whilst i'm quite happy to agree to it i
do think a better or a different wording
that is more aimed at the individual
might be helpful so i don't know if
anyone wants to like counselor wooden
i've got no words tonight but the other
thing that was quite interesting sonia
has said that
when we sign
our acceptance of office we also sign
the code of conduct
but when we sign the acceptance of
office
we're usually in a very
heady state shall we say
we're not actually reading it we're
getting a book thrust in front of us
oh gosh we've won and we're signing it
how many of us and i hold my hand up
i've never read it how many of
us read it
so can i just make a simple proposal
that might help that
after the election when we've all calmed
down a little bit
that we get a copy of what we've signed
a paper copy i think would be good as
well because i know what happens with
electronic copies they're not read
either
so that people i don't mind it being
electronic honestly but i personally
prefer paper but so that
the members especially new members have
the opportunity
to read what they've signed away from
your the um very emotive time of an
election day um i don't know if anyone
yeah
councilman would like to come back on
that i'll bring you in a second council
we'll talk about a couple other speakers
first
thank you
um
first of all um council mrs mason there
is a copy of what you sign in
everybody's pack that they're given on
the night of the election that they take
home
and so um the copy is in there
um i've listened to
what both yourself and councillor
whatton have said
and here's some slightly amended wording
if anybody would agree to this
that all members pledge to uphold the
new code of conduct and group leaders
pledge that any potential local
candidates and campaigners be required
to act in accordance with the nolan
principles
if everybody's happy with that i'm quite
happy to um amend the second
recommendation
do i need a second okay councillor
mcpherson are you proposing that i'm
proposing that okay i think
i'm sorry
would you want to hear it again
that all members
pledge to uphold the new code of conduct
and group leaders
pledge that any potential local
candidates and campaigners be required
to act in accordance with the nolan
principles
okay do you have a second for that
council
members i have got other speakers on the
original
motion but obviously we now need to
speak to the amendment
and does anybody else want to speak on
the amendment
council
we need to vote
thank you
so i'll come back to you in a second
okay what are we voting on
okay
i will get the proposal to read it again
so you know exactly
council ahoy um we now have to vote as
i've proposed an amendment to my
recommendation myself
which is that all members pledge to
uphold the new code of conduct
and group leaders pledge that any
potential local candidates and
campaigners be required to act in
accordance with the nolan principles
that has been seconded by councillor
wilkinson
members
that uh amendment is before you
those who
can speak
i'm being advised we've got to vote on
it to be able to debate it
so
there will be another vote at the end of
this so
members those in favor of the amendment
please show
with your hand i can't vote because
just have fun
those against
any abstentions
right
sorry can i ask for a point of
clarification it's normal when we have a
a motion and a seconder to allow debate
before a vote
to vote on it before it's even debated
it seems a little bit back to front to
me and certainly not what we would
normally do so can someone clarify that
thank you for that
you're voting you're not you're not
voting to accept this amendment to the
motion but you're actually voting that
you're happy to proceed with debate on
it we'll debate it and then there will
be a vote okay okay
okay
okay right what i have is 22-4 not
against and 10 abstentions
um members if you could just bear with
me a moment i need to just clarify with
officers
on
going forward bear with me just a moment
okay
members is there anybody who wishes to
speak to the amendment
council mr hoy
i'm quite contrarian as you know
if i'm told to do something i don't
quite like doing it even though i'd do
it anyway um
can it be confirmed that when we
or if we are elected
to be a councillor
the signing
of our acceptance of the
of the form where we say we accept the
code of conduct that is effectively what
we're talking about in this motion
so this is the pledge it's not a
separate pledge is it
and if there is a pledge
and we have to go and hold our hand up
and pledge
what
are the repercussions if we refuse to
pledge
um
this is also i've got no problem with
this but at all you know code conduct no
problem at
all and i do my very best to uphold it
at all times but however this is this is
not this is excluding
for instance the labour party who don't
have a group leader but who campaign
and stand for elections they're not
doing the pledge so it's a bit of an
uneven playing field on on that side as
well but i just want an answer to those
questions please
councillor mcpherson is going to come
back on that
thank you um
councillor it's a pledge
so by voting on its night
you are pledging that you will
abide by that um
our officer may clarify anything else
this is just asking for support i
honestly hand on heart did not think
that this would be that difficult to
receive support for strengthening our
code of conduct
thank you
and can i just say there is no come back
if you break that pledge as we know with
standards we know the process thank you
okay anybody else wish to
speak so
questions that i think i saw some
nodding but i don't remember getting an
answer actually but it the signing of
the form is effectively the pledge is
that correct
thank you chair councillor hoy to
confirm at the point at which
a member signs the office of acceptance
they are accepting to be a councillor
and to abide by the code of conduct and
the constitution of this council this
recommendation is using pledge as a verb
rather than a noun so that he's not
making a pledge in a hand on a bible
kind of a pledge but it's more about a a
a statement by this council that is
essentially delivered by uh passing this
resolution that's what's proposed
cancer newport
thank you chairman
i understand um
councillor mcpherson's frustration with
this uh
pledge
but
i do have an issue with it because
we
within our constitution of our local
party
we already set out how our campaigners
and candidates should behave
but for group leaders to have to
come along and enforce this or tell them
this
it doesn't work for me because
unfortunately i wholeheartedly support
it i i really do but i don't have
dealings with candidates and campaigners
in
across my group across my party not my
council in my council group i do but in
my party i don't
it's totally separate for me because
and i think you're
i think you'll even find this yourself
you may have candidates they go for a
vetting process but i can stand here and
explain the process but
some
campaigners and candidates in rockford i
may never see them
it's just the way it works in politics
but i wholeheartedly support this and
obviously
if there was an issue i would do my very
best to resolve that
and
to
and there would be recourse but that
would be within our local party
constitution
and how we select members so
i'm fully supportive of it and and
i
i am but there the wording of it
presents the issue because i'm happy to
pledge but i i already know that i could
easily break that pledge because i'm not
in control of really what's going on
with the candidates and and
um campaigners so
i think that wording does need working
on
thank you
councilwood
my perspective i think we're doing what
we do rather well in this chamber from
time to time and that is get a little
bit confused with procedure uh an intent
a wish a desire to do something which
improves something better
um
i'm not quite sure who is speaking to
the current motion or the original
motion and what i am very clear on is a
unanimous desire to strengthen and
uphold standards and what bothers me is
coming back to what we do rather well in
this chamber from time to time is try
and on the hoof come up with some words
i have absolutely no problem personally
with the words that council macpherson
has come up with um but i would suggest
that a sensible way forward could be to
defer this item bring back some new uh
wording when the um
standards committee have actually been
able to
collectively take on board the feelings
and the perceptions uh of this chamber
tonight rather than knee-jerk and start
putting words together we have tried to
do that in the past it doesn't work it's
well intentioned but i just think we
could do a lot better chairman
thank you i wholeheartedly endorse what
councillor woodson said
i don't think any of us have got any
difficulty
in the strengthening and i
take on the board councilman pearson's
concern but we're not trying to weaken
it what we're trying to make it is
workable
and we all want to encourage the highest
standards
in public life
but
i i endorse exactly what count council
would have said we can't do that on the
hook we've had
a long debate over words and whilst we
all have the same aim we're not
achieving that aim so i agree that it
should be deferred that wording could go
back and perhaps even come with three
alternatives so we can vote on
alternatives i don't know it's up to the
standards committee to sort that out but
i don't think it's this detail of debate
it's very constructive
tonight we're not getting anywhere and
we do need we do need to resolve this so
i would certainly second if we need a
secondary health daughter's motion to
differ thank you
welcome back
from mcpherson like to come back on that
i agree wholeheartedly um
councillor mrs mason um
there has been some
awkward debate on this
um however
i think the papers for this
evening came out
well in advance
which would have given a little bit of
time for people to come forward with
wording
rather than dismiss this
yes we could defer it
but i'll be passionate enough to do
something about this council and
strengthen it
and come up with a resolution this
evening
i'll leave that with you members thank
you
members i i've listened to the debate
here
perhaps i can come up with a suggestion
and certainly the chairman of the status
committee
and i'm assuming that most of the
committee members will be here this
evening
will have taken on board what has been
said
can i suggest that other other than
deferment which technically has not been
removed yet
that we accept the recommendations but
with the caveat that the record that
goes back to the standards committee for
further debate
can i offer that as a suggestion how
would members feel on that
i think
thank you chairman i'm happy to second
that
if you want to make that motion
members i'm getting advice here we've
got already got an
amendment
um
do mem can members
indicate if they're happy to accept that
amendment
before we
i'm getting confused about everybody
else and i would like um
accepted
members
so i'm getting getting advice here
um
members uh councilman mcpherson will
read the amendment and then we'll take a
vote on that amendment council mcpherson
if you'd like to read that please
thank you chairman um amended to include
um
uh the or strengthen it as was
recommended by council of whitten and
councillor mrs mason
it now reads
that all members pledged to uphold the
new code of conduct and group leaders
pledge that any potential local
candidates and campaigners
be required to act in accordance with
the nolan principles and chairman may i
ask for recorded vote if anybody will
stand with me thank you
[Music]
point of order but i've heard three um
proposals seconded i'm not quite sure
which one of them the only one you're
going to take at the moment was the
first one which councillor mcpherson has
actually just read
need out right before we actually go to
a vote council foster do you need it
read to before we go to the vote you're
happy with that right okay
sonia if you can do the recorded vote
please
cancel mrs belton
cancer mrs butcher
counselor mr carter
[Music]
councillor mrs carter
councillor constable
councillor crips
counselor fd
councillor eves
councillor foster
paul
councillor mrs gadsden
councillor hoyer
councillor lamborn
councillor mrs mason
councillor mr mason
council mrs mcpherson
counselor milne paul
councillor myers
councillor mr newport
abstain
counselor lisa newport
councillor mrs rowe
councillor sharpe
abstain
councillor mrs shaw
paul
council mrs squires coleman
[Music]
webb
councillor wilkinson for
councillor williams
councillor mr wilson
councillor mrs wilson
um
counselor
members that's 24
and 12 abstentions
members if you just bear with me a
second
we now move on to the second
recommendation
uh which i'll read out and i'll move
from the from the chair
that the lga model code of conduct be
adopted with the effect from the 1st of
august
2022.
do i have a seconder for that yes
chairman thank you councilman
anybody wish to
comment on that
okay members i'll go straight to the
vote on that as nobody's indicated
those in favor
thank you members that's unanimous
okay remember members moving on to
agenda item nine to note the minutes of
the executive and committee meetings
held between period second of february
to the 13th of july
2022
are these noted members
united chairman thank you
gender item 10.
okay a gender item 10
business from the last
or if i may
relation to amendments of notices
part 4 15.6 can we just confirm for the
for the purpose of procedure that we're
not going to fall foul or something in
the future because we've had one vote on
the amendment
my understanding of the constitution is
at that point it then becomes a
substantive motion
which we did not then do a second vote
on
so i just question whether we should be
moving forward let me just clarify that
with officers members
again
okay
i stand corrected
um my apologies
um
okay
right so we'll just go back to
and i'll just get my notes here
uh item eight five
um recommendation one
has now been amended to and councillor
mcpherson will you read it out again
please
that all members have pledged to uphold
the new code of conduct and group
leaders pledge that any potential local
candidates and campaigners be required
to act in accordance with the nolan
principles
members that is now the substantive
motion on that
item
all those in favor please indicate
thank you members put your hands down
those guys
any abstentions
members that's 24 none against and 10
absentions
that is carried
okay
members moving back to agenda item 10
business from local council office
local office sorry
business from the last council meeting
members does anyone have any questions
relating to the business from the last
council meeting
held on the 14th of june
okay thank you members
our gender item 11
report on urgent decisions
there are none
gender item 12
report of the leader on the work of the
executive
members is that noted no to chairman
sure
item 13 public questions and member
questions on notice
members there are none
item 14
motions on notice
members we have one
motion on notice
this evening
from councillor mrs mason and councillor
hoy councillor mrs mason would you like
to introduce your motion on notice
thank you chair the motion has been
circulated and i think in view of the
time of the evening and the fact that
i'm sure everyone's read it
i won't read the motion out i will speak
to it i'm sure that will be acceptable
firstly i'd like to thank the officers
for their help in drafting this motion
this council
excuse me if i read won't you it's
easier this council has an objective of
building homes for residents as outlined
in our local plan
yet our residents are facing
unprecedented difficulties
whilst virtual district council cannot
alleviate most of those problems we can
at least attempt to future-proof our
buildings
i accept that the government may
legislate on this in future but i say no
reason why rdc cannot be ahead of the
curve
in this simple respect
fitting photophotic panels will not only
help the residents occupying these
premises but will help our country as a
whole as excess electricity will be fed
back to the grid for the benefit of all
you may ask why one kilowatt per hour
the average house has a bad base load of
one half a kilowatt per hour
so this would enable the base load to be
covered during peak times and some
excesses for other electrical uses
to produce this level of electricity
with the present technology would
require up to three panels
which most properties should be able to
accommodate
points to consider
installing such energy produces
elements into our properties
that would not only reduce household
bills but also provide a smaller income
from the amount fed to the national grid
last july a 12-month
fixed supply agreement costs three
pounds per kilowatt
for gas and 18 pounds uh 18 heads sorry
three pages and 18 p see what nerves do
to you
for electricity plus the daily standing
charge of around 25 p for each fuel
a current plan being offered this month
is 17.77
per kilowatt hour for gas and 53.7 for
electricity
with standing charges of 27.22
and
46.26 for electricity
a 300 increase on the electricity unit
costs and a nearly 200 increase in the
standing charge
as a councillor
as a council i'm sure we wish to do all
we can to assist our residents against
particular costs of living increase
which is likely to get worse
indeed the money-saving expert states
that the energy price cap is predicted
to raise
by 65 in october
bringing a typical bill to 3
240 pounds per annum and will rise again
in january
we can't help our existing customers but
we can prevent some future hardship for
our residents
some points to consider
potentially photo metallic panels
systems are more cost effective to
install when building rather than
retrofitting
developers
would be able to bulk by
once the system is installed
it is easy to add to either enlarge or
add battery storage should that be so
desired
our planners would be able to consider
the roof angles
and polarization at application stage
to maximize production
i do hope that this council will see the
benefit of this motion and support it
thank you
councillor hoy are you second in that uh
motion uh yes second emotion
certainly mr councillor
councillor wilkinson
thank you chad um i completely support
this as well um i have one question the
last paragraph talks about the
exceptions because of sensitivities i
assume we're talking about the uh
settings such as the conservation area
and whatnot and what are the planners
said with regards to that are they going
to protect our conservation areas um and
would that be written in that are they
are going to protect that from these
sort of um these panels we're going in
if i may mr chairman i can answer that
that was drafted by that sentence was
actually drafted by the planners and
they were happy that that gave us some
sophistic sufficient protection
okay thank you councilman
i wholeheartedly support any motion that
goes to support what we do as council on
policy in regards to
energy efficiency and building and
planning and i do have a couple of
concerns um
i work in the solar industry although i
don't do new builds so just to put that
out there
you to fit three solar panels on a roof
is actually pretty counterproductive
whilst you can add panels and increase
system size you have to then change the
inverter re-scaffold to fit a battery
then needs a hybrid inverter you can't
mix panels so you have to be able to
hope that the panels that are originally
on the roof are still
in supply so whilst i support the i
support the motion and i support what's
being achieved here i really wouldn't
want to see us box ourselves into a
corner in saying have three panels
installed that should be a bare minimum
no solar installer would only install
three panels a one kilowatt system is is
not a good system um so i appreciate the
intent i appreciate that something is
better than nothing but my concern is if
every newbie property was built with
three solar panels on its roof they
would never have more panels than that
and really every system should be eight
or nine panels where it can fit so i i
just wanted to put that bit of
sort of thought out there just because i
don't want to see us box ourselves into
a corner thank you
council award
thank you chairman
just like to add uh some information
that that might be of use
um
at the current time
both the national planning policy
framework paragraphs one four one five
four and one five five
fully support the use of renewable
energies
but neither they or building regulations
mandate the use of solar panels or
renewable energy generation across all
buildings
whilst taking account
that all measures should reflect the
government's policy for national
technical standards
however
the council's own policy
env 7
for small scale projects and emv8 which
currently requires developers on sites
of five or more to demonstrate how ten
percent of their energy would be sourced
from decentralized low carbon
and renewable sources
the proposal contained within the motion
would seek to extend the requirements of
this policy
which i understand
the principle
of the proposal can be taken forward in
an advice note or similar guidance note
however it should be recognized that any
such note would be advisory in nature
and would not hold the same weight
as an adopted policy that had been taken
through the local plan process
the council
is unable to bring forward
mandatory planning policies
or extend
existing policies outside of the formal
local plan process
nevertheless
the council is currently working on a
new local plan which will contain
ambitious policies
with respect to renewable energy
generation
which will form the basis for future
decision making once adopted and
contribute to rochford district
council's goal of becoming carbon
neutral by 2030.
understanding of these constraints
i am content that the motion can be
taken forward as presented so i do
support it thank you
members i do have a couple more speakers
but we are very close to our maximum
time
so members i need to put a motion
forward
that are you happy
that we extend
the
time
let's say by half an hour i think that
will more than cover it
do i have a sector for that
council
council wilkinson thank you members
those in favor
please indicate
so
nice guys
any abstentions
okay members that's
4 14 against 17 no abstentions members
we've got how many minutes
13 minutes i have two speakers
um
so i will ask those two speakers to be
as quick as they possibly can
and then we'll go to the vote after
those two speakers
councillor foster
chairman
billy council award has probably covered
most of the points i was going to make
um
i'm happy to support the motion i
believe it's broadly as presented oops
sorry
sorry chairman
right
i'm happy to support the motion
um it's as is presented it's broadly uh
in line with existing policies
and uh i made
several points but uh council ward has
covered them i just remind everybody
that in the planning policy
for the evolving 2025
local plan the intended ambition
is that the sustainability target
will be go way beyond the scope of this
motion
net zero in fact subject to legal and
emerging nppf
uh policies and as council ward has
pointed out
we'd expect within that actually to have
be creating
developments that generate
net positives in energy
thank you thank you councillor foster
castle newport
very quickly if you would please
chairman quite briefly uh fully
supportive of this motion
um i think this is probably borne out
frustration of the snails pace of
government legislation and the new local
plan coming forward so
um fully behind this i think it's a good
uh motion
i think just picking up one of the
points that uh councillor belter made
earlier
about these systems and being
upgradeable in the future i think we
strongly need to look at how we
challenge
that issue
um when we
when we're um
laying down policy for developers and
how that's going to future proof or
potentially future proof the um
the systems that are implemented thank
you chairman
thank you
councillor did you wish to
sorry
council constable sorry
sorry
yes
as quickly as you can
i'd just uh like to remind members that
this motion has already been covered on
the new part l of the building
regulations which came into force in
june this year and it has also been well
covered by the latest sat regulations
which encourage the generation of
electricity
the only bit i'm a little bit concerned
about is the where the motion speaks
about other means of regeneration and
doesn't specify anything
that's just the bits that can serve me
thank you thank you
right i won't take any more speakers on
this council hoy did you wish to come
back as quickly as you possibly can
please a bit unfortunate i had a
brilliant speech written for a change
and you're not going to hear it now um
thank you for the support from the
administration um it's very welcome i
think some of the points we are covered
in here but this is a small step
which hopefully we can improve later on
and that's what i'm going to say thank
you okay council mrs mason uh can i just
quickly ask you to summarize your
emotion as briefly as you possibly can
that'll be fine thank you
members
well as written sorry has written yes
members that motion is before you those
who are happy to support please indicate
in the normal manner
those against
any extensions
okay
okay
uh it's 4 30 against zero and
extension's zero
thank you members that motion is carried
members just before i close the meeting
i would like to
say a few words of thanks
to the ladies sitting on my left here
mr director angela hutchins this is her
last meeting
she joined the council
in 2017 from
essex essex los algain
and also acted as head of paid services
and md
from november 2020 through to august
2021
and was also the returning officer
i'd like to add my personal thanks
as i had the opportunity to work with
angela both as deputy leader and leader
i'd like to thank her for all the help
she has given and i'm sure
and i'll ask if anybody else wishes to
speak but i'm sure members will join me
in saying thank you for everything that
you've done
hope that the job goes well
and i'm sure this is not going to be the
last we serve you because you're only
over the border so
hopefully we'll see does anybody else
wish to add anything to it councilwood
thank you
i too would like to
say a huge thank you to
angela
we first got to know each other shall i
say more closely
when we were working on the beagle
project
and that was a project to promote
tourism and angela's personal enthusiasm
to make that project happen and really
raise the profile on something fantastic
actually
in terms of all the other things it was
dragging in was really positive
and then a little thing called kobe came
along
and unfortunately that particular
project fizzled out through absolutely
no fault of angelas and but then it was
overtaken
in november
well november 20 we were well into it
but
the previous managing director had
decided to retire and angela moved into
the post of interim managing director
and that's where as leader i work very
very closely with angela and everything
that we did together um was faced with
the same enthusiasm and
approach of let's make it happen
and
you know at that time we were delivering
grants to businesses let's remind over
35 million pounds
was delivered to
local businesses the challenges of
maintaining our services our refuse
collection planning services licensing
and all the things that we needed to do
and angela was all over the place in
terms of making sure that the uh you
know the council delivered on those
things and then some leader came along
and said hey
why don't we think about a partnership
approach with
another authority so again angela
launched into that so we've had
several big projects as well as running
business as usual
and
i have to say really sorry to see you go
angela but absolutely delighted that
you're staying as a partner with us in
south essex and i think that is for the
strength of south essex and asella i
seem to spend quite a bit of time in
castle point these days so i'm sure our
paths are going to probably cross not
quite as much as historically
but it certainly
on behalf of
members i would like to thank you for
your huge contribution over the years
and wish you every success in castle
point thank you very much indeed
members i'm sure you're happy for me to
wish andrew all the best
it's cal castle points gain and our loss
council mrs mason
that the
majority didn't want us to be past 10
o'clock i'll be as brief as i can
which i'm very good at doing as you've
probably noticed
i first met angela at interview
and i was surprised to hear tonight that
that was five years ago
it doesn't seem five years ago i can
assure you
i'm going to be brief because i
we have a guillotine on us telling wise
and i will say that the council is going
to regret you leaving
but at the same time we wish you all the
best for the future and i'm sure you
will have a happy and successful career
at castle point so all the best thank
you
anybody else
anyway all the best angela thank you for
everything
members i'm not sure if it's a sad note
that we're leaving her she's leaving us
or it's a happy note that she's joining
us i'm not sure which way to go with
that but members thank you and i'll
close the meeting at that point thank
you members please be outstanding
[Music]
[Music]